It's Friday night.
You're in a four-player competition bowling game, the finest bowling game made.
Championship bowling.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
I'm Joe. When you play these retro games in the timeline that we're playing them in, where modern games also exist and they don't know that they're retro, so we're just kind of retroactively reviewing them, but with no nostalgia, it's hard not to compare any bowling game, and specifically championship bowling, since it's the game we're reviewing this week, with Wii Bowling, which is part of Wii Sports, the perfect bowling game inside the perfect sports game.
Championship bowling has a lot of work to do in this episode to convince me personally that it's essential, because sometimes when I think about bowling, I think about Wii Sports bowling before I even think about real-life bowling.
Wow. I don't think about that at all.
When I think of bowling, aside from real bowling, I think of that one arcade cabinet with the controller that's just a ball that you roll.
That's bowling.
See, I was also thinking a lot about Wii Bowling while playing this game, but not the motion controls, just the other controls that could be incorporated into a game that doesn't have motion controls.
So yeah, I guess I wasn't even thinking about it, but I was comparing this game to Wii Bowling.
But gotta love that ball control.
So it's a bowling game, and you know, yeah, say no more, but is, we don't usually do this, but I'm just gonna ask right off the bat, is bowling enough to suck you in?
Like, is this enough for the game, like, just the idea that it's going to be bowling?
Does it stand a chance for you here?
I mean, no.
When I saw this on the thing, I was like, okay, great.
This stands no chance to make it on the essential games list.
It might be fun, might be interesting, it might be a good simulation of bowling, but unless it's like an open world bowling,
bowling, which is the only kind of game that exists in the future, then no.
I'm personally going to keep my hand close to the vest here on whether or not I would think this could be essential,
because I don't want to spoil my vote for the essential games list, so...
I can't wait until it's just no.
It's not about spoiling.
It's not, yeah, it's not about spoiling.
I don't think... Sean did play it as if, you know,
the way he was talking just now was as if he's playing this game for the first time while we're recording,
so technically he kept everything in the correct tense.
Okay, that's fair.
That's fair. I don't want, you know, I just want to make sure the listeners all know that, like,
throughout this whole episode, no matter what I say, there's a chance that I would put it on the essential games list.
Right, but Joe, the question remains, is bowling enough to suck you in?
I, alright, I'll say this.
I think that when you say there's a bowling game, I'm already like,
that's an uphill battle.
But, it's possible.
I can see a way.
I can see it being possible.
Like, if it's just a crazy, fun, like, two-player bowling game with, like, really good...
that, like, emulates it very well, maybe.
But, let's say, like, okay, if you told me right off the bat that championship bowling,
like, you were, like, you actually got to, like, walk around the city in which the bowling alley was,
and then you'd get calls throughout the day from, like, a cousin of yours,
and they'd ask, like, hey, would you like to go bowling with me?
And then you'd go, and you'd pick him up, and you'd go to the bowling alley,
and then you'd bowl, like, ten frames.
It's basically Grand Theft Auto, but there's a bowling minigame in it.
Oh, yeah. Yeah, it's that.
Well, actually, yeah, Joe, I don't know if you caught on,
but you're describing Grand Theft Auto 4,
in which there is a bowling minigame in that, in which your cousin calls you.
That is exactly what I was doing, yes.
I actually didn't even know that, yeah.
That's so funny. I've never even played Grand Theft Auto 4.
I was just like, it sounds like Grand Theft Auto.
Alright, but to Sean's point, right, like, bowling in video games nowadays,
is more like something that's included as a side minigame that you can find.
You know, like how in Yakuza, like, there's all sorts of minigames in the casino,
or karaoke, or stuff like that.
Like, that's what bowling is now.
Nobody is releasing standalone bowling games anymore, to the best of my knowledge.
Maybe on mobile phones they are, but definitely, like,
I can't think of a bowling game being announced for PS5.
I just don't see it happening.
That would be something else. Can't even get them to make tennis games anymore, and now we want bowling?
Yeah, I hear you.
And it's, uh, I guess I'm just trying to play the crazy devil's advocate here,
because I'm, like, thinking of, like, when we played NES Golf.
Not that we voted that essential, but I was like, that surprised me.
Yeah. And I hear a bowling game, I'm like, okay, well, any sports game is going to have a very hard time with me,
but maybe it'll surprise me.
And look, we can make this game sound good.
You can choose your player.
You get to choose your ball.
You get to choose your lane.
Like, there are customizable options.
The problem is, is that when you choose your player,
it actually doesn't, like, affect their skill or their types of moves they do.
It's just their handedness is all that changes.
And choosing your ball is about choosing the weight of the ball.
How do we get to pick the color?
Yeah, seven-pound ball is always the same color.
That's how they know it's a seven-pound ball, Sean.
Well, yeah, but, I mean, if you are a real professional,
you can get whatever color you want it.
And choosing your lane is an aesthetic choice.
It doesn't create any crazy lanes where it has zigzags or something,
and you have to try to get around it.
Yeah, that's how I want, like, mini-golf bowling.
I will say, just like, as an aside,
that this did pop up on our recording schedule at probably the perfect time,
because while I admittedly haven't gone bowling in years,
I did just watch, like, a 30-minute video about, like, the science of bowling
and oil on lanes and asymmetrical weights in the middle of a bowling ball.
So, like, I'm at peak bowling curiosity at this moment.
Sean, at any moment, did they talk about control and power meters during that video?
In a way, but it was more so, like, you know, not that.
Hmm. How close did this simulate, like, the oil patterns on the lane
or the physics of bowling to you?
I mean, the only thing that I think, to answer your question seriously,
I think that there might be some simulation of an oil pattern
just in, like, when a ball hooks.
Maybe that's something that they've got cooked up in there.
But other than that, I can't really tell.
Is the oil pattern the thing that makes the ball go straight
all the way down to one inch before the pins
and then hook a very sharp left turn right into the gutter?
That is exactly what that is, yes.
Okay. I think for the sakes of this episode,
we're just going to assume everybody knows the rules of bowling
because this is exactly that.
This is 10-frame bowling.
There are no other modes.
There's no wacky new additions to video gamify it, which is fine.
But I'm just saying this is the bowling that we all know and play.
So with that in mind,
the thing that makes you able to be a bowler in this game
is that once you've chosen your character and the weight of your ball,
you get to select where you want to stand within the lane
and then how much power you want to use to throw the ball
and how much spin you want to put on the ball.
Power is done through a power bar,
similar to what we've seen in most sports games
where you have to have some kind of indicator
of how hard you're throwing or how hard you want to hit a ball.
Here, it's the same thing. It's just a swinging power meter that moves relatively fast.
Control, on the other hand,
is showing a ball moving on like a semicircle from left to right.
And if you land the ball on the left side,
it spins to the left.
And if you land the ball in the middle,
it goes straight forward.
And if you spin the ball to the right,
the bowling ball will also spin to the right.
Control seems to be the element here
that is the least communicated of the three things.
When you're standing in the lane,
wherever you stand is where you're going to release the ball from.
And that much is clear.
Power, again, we've seen it in many games.
So we're aware that like at the highest,
you're going to throw it really hard.
And if you screw up and happen to hit it less than halfway,
you're going to throw a pretty weak ball.
But control, to me, seems like
if I'm throwing to the left or to the right extremes,
my ball should be curving pretty damn hard.
And yet, it's almost encouraged
to go to the extremes here in the left and right
because of the nice spin that it puts on your ball
and the way that that hits the pins
better than throwing dead on, if you will.
I don't know if you guys experienced that.
I just thought control was the outlier here
in terms of expressing what I thought it meant.
Yeah, so I felt like during this game
that it was actually missing an entire variable
that you're supposed to be inputting for.
I would think that you should also be changing
the immediate angle that you're throwing the ball at.
The only thing that you're controlling
is the spin that you're putting on the ball
and not so much are you going to throw it
a few degrees to the right or the left.
You're always throwing the ball straight down
and then the only after effect
is that spin that finally catches
the grain of the wood at the end.
And yeah, it is sort of like you only...
I would only do the extremes
or maybe just above the extreme
because there really isn't any effect
for most of the shot.
But I also don't really...
It took me a few tries just to understand
what control actually meant
because I don't know what that icon
is supposed to represent.
Is that a bowling ball in a baby carriage?
I couldn't quite tell.
Is that supposed to be a metal...
a thing that covers food
when it's being served at a fancy restaurant?
I'm seeing a guy with a jump rope
and he's about to make his...
He's at the top of the apex of the rope
and he's about to spin it around again.
Oh my God, I see that, yeah.
And there's just like blue between the rope and the rope.
Wow, but from a very low perspective.
Yeah, he's like laying on the ground almost.
So yeah, there was just a little bit of uncertainty
when it came to what I was actually controlling here.
Yeah, the exact same thought immediately
when I played this game is like,
I'm missing a major element of control, ironically,
where I cannot angle the direction I'm shooting.
Like, I get that, that like, yeah, you're using this thing to curve it
and you can't just be like, you can't just input like a value
of how much you want to curve it
because it's not actually that easy in bowling.
But it's also not actually this hard.
You're never going to try and curve it to the left
and accidentally curve it to the right
because you did something a little too late.
Like in real bowling.
So it's weird that this thing's going so fast.
Same thing with the power.
Like your power in bowling,
one of the things that you, you know,
you have pretty one-to-one control over.
You're never going to like, oh, I accidentally,
maybe you will give it too much power, not enough power.
But like, this is the fastest moving power bar
I think we've seen.
I mean, right? So it's like, you might think you're going to get max power,
but if you're a second off,
you're going to get absolutely no power at all.
And it just feels like,
and I know we've had this kind of things
in other games before,
but it feels like it's giving you
the wrong type of challenge
to try to even remotely like bowling.
Like the challenge should come with like
thinking of the angles and thinking of the aims.
Yes. And since you can't turn the angle,
like I'm thinking of,
I mean, I know it's a more advanced system,
but I'm thinking of Kirby's Dream Course.
Have you ever played that game?
Like that game is not super easy,
but you are selecting exactly the angles
you want to shoot at. And you have to think about like the geometry of it.
Now that changes this game a lot,
but yeah, go ahead.
Even most bowling games,
what they do is,
is after you've selected where you want to stand,
they just kind of put like an arrow
where you were, you know,
a dotted line or whatever,
and you just can then choose
how you want to curve it.
Like that is something that could easily be done
on this NES game.
There's nothing advanced about that
or like, you know, there's just no graphical way to do it.
The dotted line thing
has just always been the way to show
which way you want to direct the ball.
So I agree with both of you
that it's kind of confusing
that it's not there.
To go back to the power thing,
like the reason why it's bad
is because anything less than like
three-fourths of the bar being filled
is basically like a waste of a shot almost.
Like you might get like a couple pins or whatever,
or you might gutter out or something
because you threw it so weak.
So you do need mostly max power
when you're throwing this ball,
in my opinion.
And then with the control thing,
the spin that you're applying
isn't actually showing like a spin
in the sense of like,
say you're going all the way to the left.
I would expect if I went all the way to the left on control,
that my ball would leave my hands
and immediately spin over to the gutter
before it even made it halfway down the lane.
Instead, it just kind of puts this like
gentle spin on it ever so slightly
as if I'm the pro-est bowler of them all.
And I'm curving it just enough
so that it gives it extra spins
so that all the pins,
even though I can't see them
because they don't animate well enough,
they perfectly like hit each other.
And I've done it.
Like it doesn't feel earned.
It almost feels like going to the maximum
to the left or the right
is like the best state.
Like they made that,
instead of like trying to decide
what's the best way to spin it,
it's like, nope, that's the best spin.
That's not as good of a spin.
Like it feels a little like that sometimes.
And in modern bowling,
like in real life,
like it doesn't matter how much spin you put on it.
Like during that first like two thirds of the lane,
like you're not going to see that.
So that is realistic
that crazy spin doesn't immediately gutter you out.
Again, really all this game is
is basically three different knobs
that you're tweaking
21 times maximum.
Right.
You're adjusting power,
you're adjusting control,
and you're choosing where to stand.
There's no other like,
there's no weather to take into account
wind direction like in golf,
which that would otherwise be.
There's no change in initial conditions.
The lane doesn't change over time.
So that's just what this game is.
And that's usually fine
in like a more modern bowling simulation
because there's still some of that
like that baseline satisfaction
that comes with a strike.
But what Mike just sort of pointed out,
there isn't enough detail up there in the pins
to actually get that satisfaction.
And you know, Sean,
what you mentioned about just adjusting knobs
as the way to be the player in this game,
that you're not really doing much of the bowling,
you're just kind of selecting attributes
for your character.
That winds up being a problem
because once you find the strike zone
and granted, easier said than done
to replicate the magic, right?
Given the way that the meters move around,
one spinning around in a semicircle
and the other one being a power meter.
If you can find the strike zone,
there is no reason to deviate.
Stick with, at least for the first frame, right?
The frame where all 10 pins are down there.
You, once you know where that is
and what meters those were,
there's no randomness,
maybe for better, right?
The betterness of the game.
There's no randomness in that.
It's going to perform a strike every time.
I know through own experimentation
that that is true.
And therefore, that also makes for a really boring,
like practically solved game in a way
that like, you know,
a computer could solve this game
and just stand in the right spot,
max out his power,
get the spin to be the maximum.
And all, every time,
it's going to be a guaranteed strike.
A little harder for the player,
but essentially in that kind of thing,
you're just playing one of those carnival games
where you like, you know,
just hit the buttons at the right time.
This is a reflex test rather than a bowling game.
Yeah. And I think that that's why they felt the need
to make it like,
to make these meters going so fast
and make it so it's like so hard to just,
to like, to get the power you want
and get the curve you want because they needed to make up for the fact that like,
there's no real challenge once you figure it out.
Like, it feels like,
and you know, that turns out to just not be fun that way.
It doesn't feel like bowling,
but who knows?
I might still vote it essentially.
You don't know. Well, they did do at least the bare minimum
for this kind of game.
And they included some nice animations
when you get strikes and spares,
especially if you do like multiple strikes.
You get that turkey. Yeah, exactly.
You get a turkey. And I believe like if the fifth one
or maybe the fourth one,
it's also the peacock.
Yeah, I think that's what it's called.
You get cheerleaders at some point too.
Right. So, I mean, that's nice, right?
At least they, you know,
they decided to have some fun with this game.
They, I thought based on the,
everything other than the animation
makes me think that they're being incredibly serious
about the bowling aspect.
Yeah. I mean, it's,
but it's like every bowling alley
that like I was, went to as a kid,
like half of them, I don't know why I said every
and then half of them,
but it would have some animation
after you get a strike on the screen.
So maybe this is trying to like capture that.
Well, it depended how,
how recently they had the whole thing renovated
because, you know,
some of them still had the overhead projectors
back in those days.
So they didn't have any of those animations.
You know what I'm saying? Well, I think back then
they used to just release a turkey
onto the alley.
Yeah. You know what though?
Speaking of real bowling alleys,
there's also no like neon light dark mode
or disco ball or anything.
You know, I don't know. Those things are kind of fun.
They should have at least included
another lane that was- Just like inverted colors on the NES.
Exactly. I guess you could do that.
Just something to make it feel more fun.
Maybe, you know, you can order,
you can go to the concession stands
and order a pizza
and that like affects your stats.
But it specifically states
that it's very bad pizza.
Right. Yeah.
Also, like maybe you could have selected,
well, similar to, okay, we address this very quickly,
but the player that you choose,
you get to choose between, I think, four different types of player.
The only thing that changes
is whether they're right-handed
or left-handed. There was certainly more
that could have been done
there alone, right?
But then you could also have some fun
with like the shoes that they wear, right?
Bowling shoes is something, right?
Maybe, I don't know. Sean, you watch a 30-minute video on bowling.
Do the shoes matter
or is it just all the same shit?
No, not really. At least they didn't go over it.
I'm imagining it like Tony Hawk
where you can like pick your wheels
like you can like select your shoes.
No, yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Like to make this more of a,
like a fashion thing
where you can, you know,
pick a shirt
and like facial hair
and squeaky shoes.
Like that'd be cool if you can make it squeaky.
How loosely you want your shoes tied
and how tightly and that like affects
like how much you slip down a lane.
That does simulate
like just forgetting
to let go of the ball
and going down with it.
That would have made it fun.
What's funny is
if you're not good at this game,
they have a pretty damn
high score requirement
just to get on the board
for the high scores in this game.
Most arcade games
will at least allow you
to play somewhere on the board
with mediocre scores
just this way you feel
like you've done something
and then, you know, eventually you want to work up
to first place. But in this game,
all three high scores
are just 200.
Most people never bowl 200.
Yeah, and the fact
that this is actually
based off of a real score
and not just a whatever number
that from pickups
and shooting stuff
and that this is a score
in the actual game of bowling,
I've never bowled a 200.
And I guess like I probably,
I probably did
when I played this game,
but like that's silly.
I didn't even
when I played this game,
I could, I could not get a strike
for the life of me.
I would get every,
all but one pin,
almost everything. I got it spares,
a lot of spares, but then I got a strike
I think on my last frame
I played. Joe, the tip is
you, if you're
a right-handed bowler
in this game, go over to,
go to the middle
and then go to the second dot
to the left. That's how I,
that's how I real bowl.
And that's what I was doing.
I know, I'm just saying and then,
and then curve the ball
on the control
completely to the right
at the maximum and throw the ball
like at least not maximum power,
I mean that'd be great if it was,
but like, you know, anywhere in the final three
and I can almost guarantee
I think I wasn't curving
completely to the right
because I didn't really realize
that that was the best
until this conversation.
Right, right. That, that is the best
and that's what I'm saying. That is not,
that is not clear to me
at any point
that like that would be the best.
Why would you want
to curve all the way
to the right? Spin should have been
something where it's like you want to get
close to the center
but not dead on, right?
Like you, they should have made it
like really tricky
to get the right amount
of spin in this. Instead,
they're rewarding you
for going like so far
to the polar opposites.
Also, one last,
uh, great. Yeah,
you can't change
your angle or anything
when you're,
when you're bowling but you also can't
change anything once you decide
where you want to be.
There's, there's no like
stepping out
and repositioning yourself
or taking anything back.
Like once you've, once you've selected
the control and you're on the power meter,
it's like now you're,
you can't go back
to the control. You know,
not, not really a real problem.
That's a balk in real bowling, you know,
they don't let you get away with it.
Yeah, exactly. So,
you know, it's like, I don't know,
a game that,
uh, barely has any options
to begin with. Feels like they should have
at least given you, it's not like you're like
frozen in, in your space
once you've decided
that you want to be there. They should have let you
back out from at least
the first thing. I could understand
being able to like
abuse the control system.
You would just constantly back out
until you got the one
that you wanted.
I'm going to say
that this is a simulation
of, you know,
because in bowling,
you're not just standing
straight in front of the thing,
in front of the lane,
and then, like,
flat-footedly
throwing the ball down.
Maybe this is simulating
the decision-making
of that walk-up,
you know, that, that three-stride movement.
Uh, that first stride
is determining your power,
that second stride
is determining your spin,
and, uh,
that other one is just there
because there's
no other variable.
Yeah, it's like making bowling
turn-based, like,
you have to, like, do each move,
like, all right, I'm in my walk now,
and then you gotta think
about, all right, what next,
all right, how much power?
Yeah. Joe,
one tip I forgot on the how to
bowl a strike every time
is that it does matter
what ball you choose
because that is the only thing
they decided to give
any kind of stats to.
Screw the players, it's the ball
that has the stats
in this one, and that is,
again, just the weights.
However, you know,
like a seven-pound ball
and a 15-pound ball
have big differences.
The seven-pound ball will give you
a large curve
but only a little bit
of power and vice versa
for the 15-pound.
So I found myself
in that 11-pound range
because you basically just get the best
of both worlds. You get a moderate
amount of power and a moderate amount
of curve. You don't even have to
think about it anymore.
I've always described
myself as a medium person,
so it fits.
And that's championship bowling.
There's no sequels
and spinoffs? No,
there are sequels and spinoffs,
but I was just trying
to say, like, that's the game
because it's important to note that
the long play
on YouTube
that we always link
in the show notes is five minutes
and 59 seconds long,
and this episode
is already, you know,
five times that.
So, we have a problem here
when it comes to
even the type of game
they made. There should have been
more modes.
There should have been more to it,
I suppose. The fact that it is
just 10-frame bowling
and, you know,
once you score,
once you have your score,
it just takes you to the high score screen
and, you know,
sure, you might get over 200,
probably not a real game,
but might get it here.
That's like, that's it.
Now you just get to put the name that you,
you don't even get to put the name
in at the high score, you had to put it in earlier,
so even the satisfaction
of like typing your name
in the high score is removed from you
and instead you just go
right back into this again.
So let's say,
even if this was
a good bowling game,
the content in here
is worth about six minutes.
Well, I mean,
this is just what we do,
Mike. Like, we talk.
We talk for a long time.
We talk a lot. And you asked us
to review this game.
Did you have them yelling at us?
I didn't mean to yell at you.
I mean, I didn't mean to yell.
To be, I mean,
to be fair, I think a lot of,
a lot of this episode
was also anecdotes.
So I think that was good content.
Yeah. Great.
I'm glad we're reviewing
the episode inside of it.
Probably means I should move on
to the next section, which is the sequels
and spinoffs. You'd be very surprised
to learn that they never
made a sequel for Championship Bowling.
However, I took it a step further
and decided, well,
did they make any other games
by any other developers
or publishers and also call it
Championship Bowling?
And that happened.
So let's take a look
at the other Championship Bowling games
that were released
that are definitely not
by the same developing team
or publishing team
or have any relation
to NES Championship Bowling.
Okay. Championship Bowling
on the Sega Genesis.
This game includes
three different play modes.
So they are listening
to this episode. They went to the future.
They heard us and then they went back
in time to correct things
for Sega. And their modes
are standard bowling,
which you can imagine is the normal 10 frame,
spare mode,
where a handful of pins
are just kind of placed
all over the place
and the goal is to
pick up a spare
based on where those pins are.
Okay. And then bonus mode,
where specific pins
are worth different amounts of points
and you score points
not like a normal frame.
Okay. I mean,
that at least, like,
even that spare mode,
like, where you're not trying
to emulate
the exact same thing
over and over
and your targets
are randomized, like,
that sounds more fun.
Yeah, it gives you,
it gives this, like, a little more,
like, playability,
which is weird to say
about a bowling game
that takes five minutes.
Like, well, there's no replayability
to this. But,
uh, I'm also noticing,
because I'm just watching a video of it,
this Genesis game,
uh, has a lot of interesting
character reactions in the middle of your,
of your bowl.
Like what, Joe? Well,
we got, uh,
this girl rolls the ball,
puts both hands on her cheeks,
like, Home Alone style,
like, and, and mouth wide open,
and then as soon as the ball goes down,
as soon as it hits the pins,
she's just back to, like,
a regular smile again.
Okay. So, there's,
she's uncertain,
and she's terrified.
Yeah, she's terrified, and it looks,
I gotta, I need a little more data,
but it looks like no matter what happens,
she just goes right back to smiling.
The other championship
bowling game is championship bowling
for Xbox,
the original Xbox.
I don't,
I didn't dive too deep
into this to find out what they do differently,
although they do
have this bowling,
this ball animation
that shows you
all of the meters
inside the ball
as it spins around,
and that's very hard to describe here,
but basically, like, you choose your power,
you choose your aim,
and you choose your spin
all on the same meter.
It's, it's pretty crazy,
and requires a lot
of precise timing, so I give them credit
for at least coming up
with a different kind of meter system,
that's unique. That is unique.
However, I chose this game
because this has
the equivalent
of those wacky animations
that play in real
bowling alleys,
you know, like when you get a strike,
and then it shows,
like, the craziest 3D animations
that were made, like,
you know, on, like, the same machines
that they made early Pixar films on.
Pins, that's what this,
it's like pins and balls
at, like, the Revolutionary War,
and, like, the ball, like,
muskets down at four pins
or something. And this has the same
graphical fidelity
as those. This looks really cheesy
on the original Xbox,
and, uh, clearly,
um, yeah,
I just think, like, the people who made this
were a lot more focused
on the bowling part of it
than they were on the graphics,
so, take that as a plus
or a minus, honestly,
you know, maybe you could have
a good time with that
based on that knowledge.
Also, just wanted to mention,
as I was looking through bowling games,
and obviously we talked about Wii Sports,
I feel like it's also worth mentioning
Bowling, um,
PlayStation 1. It's just called Bowling.
There's no fun title.
The cover art is just a picture
of ten real pins.
Wow. There's no, there's no character
to choose from
or even see.
It just shows you the ball,
and then you go into
a first-person view
afterwards. It's just hilariously
low effort.
Yeah. Uh, just the idea of,
like, photorealistic pins
on a cover
and being, like, bowling.
You know exactly
what you're getting. Um,
can I go back
to this Xbox version
real quick? I have a question
that you might not
be able to answer,
but I'm,
again, just watching a video
of it, and there's, you know,
behind the pins,
there's a big sign
that says Hightower Lanes,
and above that sign
you can see a little bit
of out the window.
And out the window,
it looks like in every,
every time someone's bowling,
there is a,
a fucking chopper,
just like, like,
right outside of the window,
like, looking in at you.
Like an animated
helicopter,
like, watching this bowling.
Like a helicopter
with the same graphic fidelity
as the rest of the game,
facing the window,
like, just kind of,
like, hovering back and forth,
watching, like, right outside,
like, it will crash into the window
if it goes a foot forward.
Is, like, That's terrifying.
Do we know if there's,
like, a story reason
for this helicopter?
No, that's just,
that's that location.
You're in, you're inside of a skyscraper bowling,
and so that helicopter
is just circling the skyscraper.
Oh. You could also choose
to play at a church,
and there's a nice stained glass
everywhere as the background.
These are very strange
location choices.
It's like, there was one lane,
and it was just completely,
it didn't have to do
with the theme of the bowling alley.
I mean, even being in a skyscraper,
I think it's very weird
to have a helicopter
looking in that close to you.
Well, how else? Yes, I mean,
How else are they gonna illustrate
that you're in the air?
That's true. Or like, hi,
you know? Think about it.
There's only one question
left on my mind,
and it has nothing to do
with helicopters. That is,
whether championship bowling
will be
on the Essential Games list.
Sean, your vote.
So I came in here
pretty confident
of knowing
like, what my
opinion would be
after I played this game
before I even like,
turned it on. And you know,
sometimes that can be like,
considered arrogance, but it's also just correct.
And I think that's a no.
So, Joe?
So, I've been keeping this
very secret, but I will now reveal
that
I am voting
this no.
That wasn't even a sentence,
but I'm not voting
for this to be on the Essential Games list.
And you know, maybe if they added
some helicopters, I would be a little
more likely to, but even the
manual that was
clearly made in Word,
or in Notepad,
and Notepad,
is not enough
to turn this game around for me.
I also vote no,
but as a complete
sentence instead
of what Joe did. It wasn't even worth
a complete sentence. Here's the thing.
Bowling games
are an uphill battle.
I think Sean said
that right early on,
and it's true.
Oh, it was Joe. Okay, never mind.
Sorry. Sean's never said
anything mentioning again.
Yeah. Look,
bowling games,
any game really, right?
All these NES games
have a lot going
against them in the year 2022.
You can't just
offer us,
you know, one mode
and have it all
be the same thing
and have it just be
pressing, you know,
pressing buttons to get meters
to move to then experience
bowling animations.
That's the issue,
right? Is that it's not even like
we're bowling. we're just watching
someone bowl based on three inputs
that we happen to press.
That's not going to get
on the essential games list
and it didn't.
And it's done.
It's done, but the podcast
is not done. Next week,
Cybernoid, the fighting machine.
I don't know. What do you guys think?
I like it.
No idea. Cybernoid?
Cybernoid, the fighting machine,
most likely not a bowling game,
so that's something to look forward to.
Well, with a name like that,
I'd be pleasantly surprised
with the bowling game. Just like that would be bowling.
That would be wild.
Yeah, that might be what bowling needs.
Not even bowling games,
just real bowling. We need like cyborgs,
battle bots.
And if you don't want to wait
until next Friday to hear from us again,
you can talk to us directly
on our Discord.
But there's a catch.
It's only for Patreon subscribers,
patreon.com slash nostalgia.
Honestly, $1 will get you in.
We're not trying to be exclusive about this.
$1, and you can have access
to the Discord, and you can go on
the Essential Games list channel
inside the Discord
and tell us how wrong
we are about everything.
Literally just write the longest post
you can imagine. Everybody else
who's a patron gets to read it to
and agree with you
as you yell at us
basically for a dollar.
You get to, you know, like think about
how many people in your life
would you give a... Right.
How many people in your life
would you give a dollar to
just to make them cry?
Now you can do it virtually.
Yeah, and if it does make him cry,
we have like a gentleman's agreement
that he will record himself crying
and post like a little like gif of that
in the Discord
if you've actually made him cry.
In the Discord
and also on LinkedIn.
Yes, on his LinkedIn specifically.
he'll make that his profile picture.
Okay. Okay. Thank you.